Gracias.
Mi subsistema de neuronas espejo sugiere que esto va a reemplazar a los teléfonos
muy pronto.
Ray, ¿cómo te va?
Ray: Bien. Estamos en directo hoy.
(Aplausos)
MG: Ray, ¿no le haces un regalo al público?
¿El cerebro holográfico que vimos en el video anterior?
Chicos, esta tecnología no solo cambiará a los teléfonos
sino también nuestra forma de colaborar.
Muchas gracias.
Gracias, Ray.
Ray: De nada.
(Aplausos)
MG: Así que amigos, este es el mensaje que descubrí en aquel bar en 2011:
El futuro de la informática no está encerrado detrás de estas pantallas.
sino aquí, dentro de nosotros.
(Aplausos)
Así que si hay una idea que quiero difundir hoy aquí,
es que la máquina natural no es una ficción del futuro,
está aquí en 2016.
Es por eso que cientos de nosotros en Meta,
incluyendo el personal administrativo,
los ejecutivos, los diseñadores, los ingenieros,
antes de TED 2017,
tiraremos los monitores externos
y los reemplazaremos por máquinas mucho más reales y naturales.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)
Muchas gracias, de verdad.
Gracias, chicos.
Chris Anderson: Aclárame una cosa,
ya que ha habido unas cuantas demostraciones de realidad virtual
en el último año, más o menos por ahí.
Y a veces hay un debate entre tecnólogos
sobre si realmente vemos cosas reales en la pantalla...
Está el tema del campo de visión,
ya que la tecnología muestra una vista mejorada
de lo que en realidad se vería usando las gafas.
¿Vimos el modelo real antes?
MG: Por supuesto.
No solo eso,
tomamos medidas adicionales para filmar con una GoPro a través de la lente real
en los diversos videos que acaban de ver.
Queríamos tratar de simular la experiencia del mundo
que estamos viendo realmente a través de estas gafas y sin cortar nada.
CA: Muchas gracias por la demostración.
MG: Muchas gracias, muy agradecido.